you can upset people sometimes in your
show people do get upset and they will
walk out of your show most people in the
crowd enjoying it having a good time but
you'll hit a nerve with some people who
will get up and walk out here and that's
that that a regular occurrence for you
well it what two tours ago yeah was
happening a lot and this tour not not
nearly as much very very little but but
there definitely were some walk outs but
there was one incident in particular
where I was in Pittsburgh and you should
probably hear him out first
[Laughter]
excellent point no it was it was a great
show it was a great show and I and it's
another place where I have really good
shows it's fun but we so was at this
theater and and in the middle of the set
maybe a third of the way through there
was a also it was a theater with and
there were security you know theaters
provide security so there's a guy
security you know on the windbreaker and
security on his t-shirts to the stage
left sitting there and I'm just doing my
set well a lot and then he just
when I say yells I mean he screams yells
and it was right at the perfect moment
where I was you know he couldn't have
timed it any better I was talking about
something and he goes this is [ __ ] I
quit and the security guard he was
afraid to be there I hate to be there
protect you protect me and any leads in
a big huff and and everybody thought it
was a plant everybody's like oh this is
a good bit threw me it was like crazy
and I thought I to thought for a second
you know like is this a fan doing a bit
but he's a security guy you could see
him like you know he's angry flipping
the bird and he leaves and and he was
yes he's security provided by the
theater to protect me from him
[Laughter]